في موضوع اخر مشاهدينا طور باحثون في
جامعه اريزونا يمتاز
بقدره او طوروا روبوت يمتاز بقدره على
التنفس وايضا الارتجاف بل والتعرق بغزاره
حينما يكون الجو حارا تماما مثل البشر
هذا الروبوت تستخدمه شركه الملابس
الرياضيه لقياس الضغوط التي تسببها
الحراره والتي لا يمكن تجربتها على شخص
حقيقي طبعا يعمل الباحثون على قياس تغيرات
درجات الحراره حسب حاله الشخص فمثلا مريضه
السكري تتغير درجه حرارته او درجه حرارته
بشكل مختلف عن اي شخص اخر
بالتالي هم يريدون معرفه مدى سوء تاثير
هذه الظروف على حياه الانسان وصحه
وفي قدره على التعامل معها لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات